security is a critical concern for any
web application a secure app must
prevent unauthorized database operations
as well as validate the integrity of
incoming data firebase allows you to
define database security logic and a
JSON file that corresponds to the
structure of your database the no sequel
database is essentially just a series of
nodes and each node can have its own
validation and security rules for
example you might have some data that's
accessible to everybody that visits the
site or you might have some data that
should only be accessed by authenticated
users or other data that's only
accessible to the user that created it
and this lesson I'm going to go through
all these different scenarios and show
you how to implement these or Squier
based database rules you can define
firebase rules directly from your
angular project or from the firebase
clone form personally I prefer using the
firebase console because you can send
test requests to make sure that your
rules are working properly there are
three types of rules you can set read
write and validate read controls access
to data write controls the ability to
create edit or delete data and validate
control format of data you can use any
combination of these rules together or
none of them at all there's also a
series of variables that give you access
to firebase resources auth gives you
access to the user authentication state
roof gives you access to the root note
of the database data gives you access to
the data as it appears before the
operation takes place new data shows you
how the data will appear after an
operation takes place now gives you the
UNIX timestamp for the current time
there is also a wild card variable that
you can use to reference any child key
throughout the database now let's run
through some of the most common security
scenarios Google might run into first we
can just disable all security so anybody
can read or write to the database we can
put everything on lockdown to where
nobody can redirect to the database we
can limit access to only authenticated
users who are currently logged in we can
also limit users access to only content
that they created we do this by using
the wild card variable that we talked
about earlier in this case we have some
data as nested under a user ID so we can
then reference that user ID to make sure
it matches the current auth ID of the
logged in user in this example we're
only going to allow users who have been
flagged as moderators to write data to
the database we do this by first setting
a moderator variable to true somewhere
else in the database then we use the
root variable to traverse to wherever
that point is you can also use firebase
rules to validate the integrity or
format of incoming data in this case I'm
validating that some input is a string
and that it's at least one character
long but less than or equal to 140
characters
[Music]
the now variable allows you to validate
whether some data calls within a certain
time frame in this case we're checking
to make sure the post doesn't have a
timestamp that fall at a future time you
can validate that new data has certain
child attributes by calling the get
children function and then passing it an
array of the attributes that you want to
check
lastly you can validate the existence or
the non-existence of data before
performing some kind of operation this
is useful because it allows you to
control whether or not a user can create
update or delete some data a common
pitfall with firebase rules is that once
you grant access to a resource
it can't be revoked somewhere further
down the tree so you always want to err
on the side of caution and only grant
access when specific credit conditions
have been met so in this example you can
see that we granted access initially but
then try to deny access later in the
tree to only authenticated users when we
run a test to this rule we see that it
fails NIT grant access to the user that
should not have access so when we
reverse this around and deny access
initially we can see that the rule then
does work we send the corresponding
request
that's it for database rules thanks for
watching
[Music]